welcome to this video playing tacticals
again from Hungary Sultan made VG VG ok
the English opening I'm not sure how he
plays that I was g6 ok so we're going to
transpose into this panel and pull off
set up that's a very interesting way to
play a play this as black myself just
try to think of what to do I guess I
start with queen bee three it's not
clear can also start with Bishop c4 this
is a neat little trick 6 check we get
this this this interesting position
Black has got two bishops but he also
has slightly weakened formation with the
pawns all on light squares and yeah the
dark squares are our problem let's see
can I do something how can i play this i
can just develop obviously Bishop f4 and
Luke c1 things like that I wonder can I
get can I do something something
different get this Bishop exchange
somehow
it's not not really a parent okay that's
just complete development i hope to see
one the usual stuff he might play c5e IM
just like that maybe I can manage queen
bee three Bishop d2 before would be nice
f6 was was played to patch up the e5
square very common way to play here if I
go to be 3 SC what is he doing he cannot
like will be 56 hangs he can trade but
I'm not sure about that I mean I have 92
c 4 a 5 those kind of ideas interesting
and true create this Bishop f4 very
interesting structural transposition
here
I also was a game aronian gelfand from
the candidates 2013 where they played
this opening I think they also got to an
end game of this this type not not
entirely sure but it was it was this
opening and maybe this is kind of this
kind of endgame ok isn't this a double
attack be six and A five
maybe he didn't really see that be
success and I can I can win the exchange
now Jack probably should check and
probably really should the check and I
just flicking this in is probably a good
idea forgot about this one need to get
the bishop traded
hmm oopsie force Bishop a six some way
to get it traded maybe I first played
this and now I can can get in Roxy to
Bishop g2 okay activate the king this is
not a not a super easy technical task I
mean why should I should win it I mean
not not managing would be disappointing
but it's not like not like super easy
and obvious I guess still here in Bishop
g2 can I get maybe the king over first
he might have a five and okay this is
probably useful in any case
meet this and then we should be 20 kg
five probably okay hoopty for Bishop
takes rook take this look 28 and I'm
trapping a special so I probably get the
bishop trade in now
mind if we exchanged looks it should be
pretty simple root G for Bishop takes
rook the one I mean this should be
should be very simple win king see to
look c4 and then I'm pushing him back
maybe g5 still and Bishop g6 but okay I
have a set up here with rook on c3 that
is very very tough time too okay can go
okay it is not Bishop b5 rookie three
wins easily threatening rookie for and
rookie six okay so I can check and
pushing back now if i go here shop g5
that's a bit bit awkward for the rook in
fact
okay better but to improve the Roku
first him and now we can go to differing
and desserts for stupid
poor this was not good just just not
good oh how bad did I play that time are
unspeakable
hmm check is that you you know way
through to make make something happen
here maybe with f5 I still want to try
to win also played this like a total
idiot of course now I can also lose it
giving him those pawns but add man that
was really really terrible check
I cannot even go to a six that's it gets
better and better oh Christ Wow Oh
terrible game I mean not the first part
first part I played okay maybe I can
somehow was still draw it check check
read it check white forfeits on time
yeah I can master this is one of those
kids where I should be shot for this
this game unbelievable black was
completely busted and I didn't didn't
put this away this end game is totally
winning totally I looked you to way I
can just resign yeah and it said ah now
this is totally totally over okay let's
check how I played it and I really
thought once I get him back there it
should be easy but the problem was I
wanted to originally play this of course
but my rook is in a bit of trouble on
the on the fourth rank I mean where is
the route going
maybe memay this this is probably
probably the win but this was not easy
to figure out yeah this wins this wins
rather easily and it all started when I
didn't do that around here black gets
gets very active very active position
still of course I shouldn't lose but I
wanted to still try to win it check and
this is probably inadvisable five-year
computer still gives me a pretty clear
win but it wasn't check wasn't easy and
here it's not not not not good anymore
look Dee for a stronger I mean I
definitely shouldn't lose button by now
we come to a position where black is
just easier to play rugby six was
especially idiotic I can just play rook
h6 this is much better i will get this
yeah i can draw but this was just the
whole trend was was just simply bad from
this totally winning position to too
tricky to to lost I am I made 11 very
crucial mistake here here I should have
spent some some more time maybe to
figure out if my Ruca strapped if it is
not trapped then this is simple win
because his king is sold by head back
here and he has no way to defend this
this is the the best line the compass
giving and I can always go to a 4 of
course I totally forgot about a 4 yeah
then this is very simple I only need to
make sure my rook is getting back into
play and then this is very easy because
no my queen side is not weak and i will
just in wait with the rook it's a pretty
pretty simple technical win oh man
thanks for watching